[Music]
hey guys you're watching out the record
where we talk about whatever we want and
I just yeah you burned or dude you
burned or good hell yeah yeah okay
Animal Crossing you guys been talking
about this for the last damn hour amount
of information I mean what is it cuz
mean the demon Jude are out of the loop
the addicting game of all [ __ ] time I
have a theory that Nintendo made
coronavirus because it came out the
exact same time as a carnival it could
be okay but what is this though what is
it it's like you get to live your
alternate perfect life as a cute tiger
in a cart no no you're a person everyone
else is the fandom oh my god I need this
game yeah you're a human and you're just
with animal dude you can buy so many
clothes - oh my god you're talking my
language you have to have a wand in
which you to pick out any outfit you
want whenever you're running around or a
wardrobe okay so is it like GTA but no
thuggery where's the fun it's like that
or it's like Minecraft you have missions
there's something for everybody no
there's no there's well sometimes
they'll be like a fish tournament or
someone's like hey can if you help me
find my thing that I lost I'll give you
a recipe on how to make a bookshelf yeah
so it's like minecraft yes with no
agenda we cute earth not as scary
there's no zombies oh and also you don't
have to try to survive or anything it's
really relaxing you're just living your
[ __ ] best life so how does one go
from like call duty to that it's like if
you want to chill and not like have to
worry about people killing your mama to
kick back listen to a podcast just kind
of [ __ ] around
yeah listen to a podcast this no no but
then this is even more active than that
how do you guys communicate to other
players do type yeah you can type in
it's not very not abused like the Animal
Crossing Nintendo Abby
Just Cause each other in that you guys
you guys if you're trying to get me
addicted to this okay about working it
sell you on it because I keep getting
interrupted so ok you start off and
you're on this island at first like for
the first three days I played this game
I was like I don't see that what the
hype is it's like not that fun very
Furby to give you three days right yeah
okay like an hour here and there you
know I was like whatever it's not that
fun but because you start off in a tent
and there's nothing around you it's just
this ugly ass island with weeds
everywhere and you get like you have to
make a fishing pole and then you start
fishing and that's actually kind of fun
because like you have to learn a certain
technique to fish and like you have to
wait till the fish bites and anyway and
then you prefer bug catching good but
you see what the fish is and like you
the first couple of fish you catch these
are like brand new like you catch
different fish every time and you give
them to the raccoon and then you open a
museum
where's my [ __ ] wood okay the raccoon is
the guy you're right you to the island
and please the Mafia you're living in a
tent but then as the game starts to
progressing he's like yo you sick of
living in that tent cuz you can have a
house if you want you're like okay I
want a house and then he doesn't tell
you till after you get the clothes but
now you owe him for $1000 can record a
loanshark he's like okay he tricks you
yeah he didn't tell you that the house
was gonna cost a lot of money so Nicky
wasn't interested in the game until she
realized she had a debt to pay so what
if I don't want it I don't wanna yeah
now I know well I have to be in bed but
yeah and also you want your life you
start collecting these things from
balloons that drop by you have to shoot
down these balloons and you'll get like
furniture pieces but if you try to put
in your tent
it looks really cluttered it's very bad
but then when you upgrade to a house you
get storage do you have like an
inventory you could store things in
there and also you could to design it
like Pinterest level designing your
house you could customize it you can
like collect different things but then
sometimes you go to other people's
houses you're like how the [ __ ] they get
that oh my god that looks so cool you
get ideas when you go to the other can
go to other people's Island how do you
go to their Island it just sounds like
Sims and minecraft put together kind of
The Sims no raccoon from the other two
it sounds right the sims got corny
though yeah this I haven't played Sims
an age in the island you're in there you
[ __ ] developed this [ __ ] also every
time new [ __ ] gets developed they give
us they do a ceremony and then they like
congratulate you on how good of a job
you do that's not corny really needed
that in Rio my real life because I feel
like I don't get credit for how good of
a job I do and I'm like man it feels
good and get some [ __ ] credit for
these beep can you give her some credit
please oh it's not my problem
for these bridges that I built you give
her a lot of credit oh yeah
good job Nikki you get to earn reactions
okay you don't just get them oh the best
thing is what I complement she's like I
know honey but you say that all the time
that's special when it comes for you
from your significant other well I think
your dad calling you the most beautiful
girl in the world it's like my dad never
call me that he would always call me
stinky and I'm like I called you
thinking we first got together
yeah it's true you call me to botchoy
which means chubby in Filipino kabocha
antibody that's him sake you know it's
cuz I wouldn't stop eating oh yeah I
just thought it was the most ironic
nickname and it's not a nice big name at
all but the idea that I'm like you're my
stinky I love you you're my stinky and I
just I just started work know what that
the first couple weeks of our
relationship is very fun I hate it did
you know that her dad called her that I
had no idea what she's doing he didn't
call me stinky you would didn't use that
term that's your term he called me like
a fat [ __ ] or like no fat chick for
dude that is hilarious he loves you you
are my dad
she loves you a lot he does I mean I
understand it you didn't know until
later in life that was me
you made a sign you fat [ __ ] oh you
know fat oh no what would be allowed in
I think that was his joke cuz everytime
I gained weight he wouldn't call me a
fat [ __ ] anymore like it's funny
because you're not bad that's yeah yeah
yeah yeah you only call me that if he
thought that I was looking okay that's
why I called her stinky she never
smelled out of every it's funny to call
people the opposite like Bart is
obviously athletic and we used to call
them fat all the [ __ ] yeah all the time
yeah but when you actually got fat we
stop calling them so for me I carried
the way for you drew the one that calls
and all like that's hurtful to you like
it's the significant others supposed to
do that yeah yeah that's right
it's like it's helpful because then it
puts them it kicks them in a higher gear
because we know their full potential
guys guys guys can't do that to girls
true yeah even when they know guys can't
do it to girls if they don't want sex
anymore so that's a great way to refuse
sex
yeah cuz basically I don't want you to
see me naked until I work on my chiseled
ABS and so until you and then I'll be
ready for you y'all see your naked
student help hopefully no she what we're
talking about that's not you what the
chiseled abs well no like the person who
absolutely do not have person it's about
nursing then the person who's gonna wait
until like us perfect time to no no no
way you're not gonna wait for it will
determine like what how I dressed like
if I keep a shirt on or like if I'm
gonna dress up and get put lingerie on
like I want like my body to look I wanna
feel like you want to feel yourself yeah
and if I feel all bloody then it's just
gonna be interesting me naked but I'm
gonna be under the covers okay I'm not
ready today
kind of bloated yeah I don't think Steve
could tell the difference probably not
yeah but that's not a the same Steve
never calls me fat though cool but if he
did call me fat I would be like it's not
a good feeling okay Nikki I saw a good
feeling you know where your old uncle
fat your
not to call the girls fat in their ass
yeah Nikki gotta say this it's like ah
now hey you girl you got some fat tits
Congrats in the 90s that wasn't okay
right I wonder why
you know JLo got a butt reduction that's
why I found it odd because like it's
evil sometimes talking about how I have
got a big butt and all my life everyone
told I had a big butt and I'm like dude
I got made fun of it all so I'm not I
like it I like it but you know I got
made fun of it for a lot but then people
here will be like I can't believe Nikki
you think she has a big butt like oh my
god like why are they saying he has a
big butt because I realized that now has
a big butt you know because they have a
gigantic [ __ ]
well now it's popular on Instagram and
stuff to get butt implants are to like
work your butt out there compared to
like massive I don't work out to make my
butt huge it's just there it's there I
don't I don't need it you have a perky
butt for someone that just said they
don't work out on it I literally played
Animal Crossing for 11 hours yesterday
they're comparing they're comparing her
to obese women no Instagram people that
get butt implants now and they do a
million squats to get like a snatched
waist and a big ass they also assume
that you are bragging even though that's
not what you're doing no it's just a fad
they just have an ass
who's bragging though they assume that
assume that I'm like Nick he's like I am
the big butt girl I'm yeah right yeah
and it's okay you can brag you'll be
like brag all the [ __ ] you want
don't you brag I don't even work out
dude I brag the I [ __ ] brag so hard
if I had something to bracket people big
boobs and they're like oh if you had
them you wouldn't want them I'm like no
I think I want them I didn't have them I
got them I like them yeah gave it up
they didn't know the other side geo what
implants I you know what guys are
getting more Sergi surgery now than
women are
yeah an mtv a lot of guys get dipped in
[ __ ] [ __ ] with no bob jawline jawline
filler Botox or whatever dude you don't
need a better job you just lose weight
it'll be [ __ ] chisel but that's hard
that's the hard part
what just lose weight just lose weight
is yeah it's just okay I'm just I'm just
trying to let you know that's man talk
maybe we didn't let you know bro that
the easier thing to do I think is that
yeah because if you look the way that
you do right now a big giant teddy bear
and yet with chiseled jawline it doesn't
look right don't you lose weight
translate what you just said Joe thinks
you're [ __ ] hot and if he was a woman
he'd [ __ ] you because you've already had
he said that he would [ __ ] you if you
drop some weight okay your body fat
percentage is this much it needs to be
this much maybe there might be a job it
was pretty unhealthy to that's what I
heard but I do want to save you
basically save Botox woman they're
trying to twist my words the deme I call
you fat Joe's the guy no Joe the guy who
is in a relationship with you and then
he's like and then you order and then
he's like are you sure you don't want to
salad and you're like that's bar to your
night alone Joe yeah all I'm saying is
you don't need a chisel your jaw line
cuz you probably got one underneath
probably I don't have a job I don't know
if I have a jar you saying he's not sure
no no you you probably got one
underneath I'm just saying yeah you have
a 99% chance yeah because you got abs
underneath you probably be saying you
don't need to get surgery to get a job
put in because you'll never see anyways
behind hope that you have kids so you
could share all this love in your heart
with them as well cuz I think have you
seen the know how they get the ABS Botox
oh yeah it was just fat but they get rid
of like the little spots here and then
you have abs now let's [ __ ] hilarious
those it dude the kids all shot it's
just all fat have you seen the guy that
just presses up against the fence yeah
my feel oh he does that there's a
surgery to to get that line yeah like
they fold your abs in to get that line
they literally split it apart yes hello
guys are getting [ __ ] yeah you AB
still work the same
I think what's the recovers I don't know
after childbirth that's kind of nuts
right oh yeah how's what do mean they're
nuts like they get torn if you're like
working out if you do something but no
they don't get generally they don't get
what these your abs are [ __ ] up right
yo they come back what i but i know
during right isn't it pretty nuts no
nothing happens it's only afterwards you
have to be it's all loose it separates
it could separate separate separates
right they can't separate like let's say
if you're working out or whatever then
it will separate then you need surgery
to bring it back together but that's how
they tell you to just chill out after
birth I heard a lot of guys are getting
mad surgery now though like from calf -
but - just ABS and like yeah and a lot
of face should turn off to me to be
honest what surgery yeah poor guys does
it show that they're insecure and
they're not really an you know what I
know no you know what it is it's society
for shame I gotta marry now you're not a
man am I not a man because I want to get
surgery it's definitely a double
standard I would say because yeah you're
right you're like okay in society that
like and this is not my personal beliefs
but they put mine beauty they emphasize
beauty for women beauty and youth for
women and then for men it's status and
money oh yeah I like that one those are
the key to the society tells you you
have to have so when a man starts doing
like the beauty stuff or like the vanity
stuff it just seems a little it could be
compared to like a girl like caring more
about a status and money over like it
doesn't take care of herself I don't
know well those are just [ __ ] feel
like working out like you guys working
out like you penises that's a that's a
beauty personal get cosmetic surgery is
more Beauty to me the guys strong it
doesn't seem like cosmetic no for me at
least um I forgot like I don't I would
have a trouble dating a guy that was
getting plastic surgery because I want
to feel like I'm being taken care of and
I'm like and if you're reneging like
it's all fake like like you're in the
I'll have to take care of you now
because you bought plastic surgery I
gotta feed your oatmeal cuz you got a
face job I mean an odor and I know how
muscles work you know what I mean if you
want an ass I know that you can work for
an ass if you can gain an ass but like
as a guy you gain it when you're working
out which means you're strong and
capable I feel like they cheated yeah I
think about girls who get buddy I
[ __ ] hate females that get [ __ ]
plastic [ __ ]
here's the thing though is that like
also sexually guys are visual people
like they'd get turtle yeah oh yeah so
yeah I get plastic surgery to get like
breast implants let's say upgrade you
benefit from it looking at it so like
when you get breast implants I'm not
turned on by it and you attract more
success guy with breast implants I'm I
like it okay Gio Oh God do you like lez
be important oh that's why it comes off
as maybe gay what when guys do it a
little bit do whatever you want
guys should do whatever they want yeah
there's someone for everyone in the gay
community it's is similar we're like
youth and and beauty is held on the
pedestal you want young boys I just said
boys but that's just like in the
straight community how you when you're
50 you want a 25 year old piece of ass
that's right by 419 that's against
status it's like saying like you are at
a status where a 25 year old hot chick
would want you exactly I wouldn't mind a
hot young girl that's also money driven
and successful that's like and I have to
work less that's dull right it's
personal you have to look good huh I
mean you have to look really good really
what do you bring in to the table you
you Lamborghini every personality what
about bad money oh so you don't want her
to have a personality no I mean like how
come they can't just love me for me yeah
how come they can't love me for me no
matter what me I am including a very but
I have to be so superficial
what do you like about them ha
and money so we could travel and [ __ ]
all over the world why do they have to
be so superficial I know I need to feel
what they don't have which is
personality need unity balance a hot not
superficial girl that just likes you for
you yeah and that makes a lot of money
oh yeah and owns a private plane she's
very generous
Kardashian at the age I mean she might
be old but you can find her no no no I
said young one Oh young I miss em I bet
one of the Kardashians I'll take them no
one wants an old [ __ ] Geo what do you
find that under only only only only
sorry highly successful unexpired 22
year old we already married so girl from
a 22 year old 22 year old much they know
all the time huh I'm a 24 and like I
wouldn't even date a girl that's a 22
I'll take away wait why it just seems
young remember we were talking about the
car how like there just know everything
oh yeah yeah I mean guys I feel like I
feel like I'm 30 I feel like it's a huge
age discrepancy you just haven't found
the right one that's true I disagree
strongly I think the two years is not a
big big but I think that five years came
what do you want a 22 year olds
everything she could be 40 but she looks
22 I'm down that's right I think five
years is tops for me because then you
can well some of the similar things
growing up and stuff exactly what I
think there's an age limit for me like I
I've been attracted to all ages I need
to I mean not kids but like I took the
illegal age yeah I mean I'm not gonna
sit here and say I would never ever like
or whatever it's about personality and
how you carry yourself and maturity
level and all that stuff it's not the
age it's the mentality yeah who said
that
a 22 year old he said a hot dogging
two-year-old that was a very specific
number well you guys push me to a number
so I had to choose you in the worst yeah
and it was good for the video but a
reality I'll take an old hag any day but
as long as she has money hell yeah and
she's hot do you guys remember the
fitness girl
she was she was really popular on
[ __ ] fitness.com or whatever but it
was like no bodybuilding.com the mom
chicken tuna what her name was chicken
tuna man she thought it'd be something
whole dude her body was amazing and I
was like at 50 something Oh Carl
whoo I'll take you like you're 22 well
how do you take a 22 you
she probably take you like you're 20 -
that's true don't like that Joe does
like I do Joe told me on our live chat a
night that he wants to be overpowered by
two women at the same time that's his
fantasy you know that meme I showed them
the [ __ ] girls I have to do my math
homework first that's my dream right
there one of the girls is sucking on the
guy's nipple and he's like please don't
ya this that's great
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]